I am Legend the 2007 blockbuster
starring Will Smith and a bunch of CG
zombie things called Dark seekers was
pretty popular becoming the
highest-grossing film of the year it
raked in over 500 million dollars
worldwide and Warner Brothers
immediately greenlit a sequel but it
never happened here's why we never got
to see I am Legend to Will Smith never
really seemed into it in 2012 Will Smith
spoke with the BBC to promote the
upcoming men in black 3 when asked about
appearing in a follow-up to I am Legend
Smith didn't waste his words producers
are working on it I'm not actually
working on it if it's great I'm into it
I don't want to be the sequel guy when
you're promoting a sequel and then say
that you don't want to be the sequel guy
in relation to another project that's
getting a sequel well that's pretty much
that
to his credit Smith's been pretty true
to his word he's acted in over 20 movies
I he's only appeared in three sequels
men in black 2 and 3 and bad boys 2 and
that movie was worth it just for this
just got real and let's not forget he
declined to come back to the
independence day sequel in 2016 and not
even the lovely Margot Robbie could
convince him otherwise I'm not doing it
okay if he can say no to her he is
definitely not the sequel guy prequel
plans still even without Smith during a
follow-up to I am Legend might have been
tough as you may recall Smith's
character Robert Neville died at the end
of the original film which makes it kind
of difficult to pick up the story where
it left off then again that didn't stop
Terminator 3 hi
anyway that's why Warner Brothers
started pursuing a prequel which
according to a 2008 article in variety
would have shown the final days of
humanity in New York before a man-made
virus caused the plague that left
Smith's character the lone survivor
among a mutated mob in the city that
sounds kind of cool except the first
movie already used flashbacks to show
the military quarantine of the city
Nevel valiantly decided to stay behind
and then helplessly watched as his wife
and daughter died in a helicopter crash
during the evacuation that kind of
covers the dramatic beats leading up to
his solitary existence in the original
film so nope rather a reboot roughly
four years after the prequel plans hit
the dead end
Warner Brothers announced yet another
plan to develop the franchise according
to Deadline in 2012 the film is not
being called a prequel which have been
rumored for the past few years by 2014
and with Will Smith having famously
declared himself not the sequel guy the
project took yet another turn this time
according to another deadline article as
a sci-fi version of The Searchers
that's right The Searchers the John
Wayne Weston from 1956 that follows a
posse of cowboys on a mission to get
revenge and retrieve a kidnapped girl
but probably in this case the kidnapped
girl is like a zombie or something one
producer said it will never happen I am
Legend scribe and blockbuster generates
a Kiva Goldman have been the go-to guy
for the sequel plans from the beginning
but even he apparently had his doubts
about the new installment ever happening
he laid it all out to io9 we've tried
every which way in fact if you're
available you could be in the next movie
it will never happen but we really
enjoyed trying to make it happen zombie
fatigue may be the biggest problem of
the I am Legend sequel is coming up with
an idea that seems well fresh our
research reveals that since 28 days
later reignited the genre in 2002 the
number of zombie related projects has
climbed to approximately a gazillion
sure I am Legend was one of the most
successful zombie flicks out of a solid
group that includes Dawn of the Dead
zombie land and World War Z but that was
mostly due to its early position in the
new zombie wave as well as Will Smith
star power both of which have
significantly faded in recent
the walking-dead still draws solid
ratings but on the big screen it's a
different story for proof see Pride and
Prejudice and Zombies
or don't no one else did Warner Brothers
will be smart just to let this one go
after all does anything really good ever
come from resurrecting the dead thanks
for watching subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the
one you just saw and leave us a comment
and let us know what you would have
liked to have seen in I am Legend -